e é precisamente sobre isso que vim
buscar solar é não aquilo que estamos
habituados ever sobre futebol na
televisão é vermos os jogos os 22
governo como eu costumo dizer mas sim em
outro lado o treino é essencialmente o
processo de ensino aprendizagem e sei
que é o treino e todo tudo isto é comum
em muitas áreas da nossa sociedade é
como uma escola é é comum em qualquer
área que seja preciso aprender e mais do
que falar do processo de ensino
gostava de falar do processo de
aprendizagem é nisso que tenho focado
essencialmente no futebol e no futebol
porque eu considero que o futebol
pertence à área
se nós olharmos para o futebol como
sendo a arte é que vamos ser capazes de
entender porque eu acredito que é mais
difícil aprender do que ensinar surdo
quando falamos de uma área da arte como
a pintura como a música e eu acredito qo
futebol e acredito que o futebol
português artes porque ele encaixa na
definição em primeiro lugar de ser
praticado puros hoje e quando é
praticado por pessoas que eu dependia de
sua criatividade depende da sua
imaginação e mais eu completam acredito
que é essencial para a sociedade é algo
de inútil el é computar um quadro eu
quando vou pintar um quadro só vou
pintar uma vez em quando vou jogar um
jogo de futebol
só vou jogar uma vez quando eu acredito
que está o mal é que hoje em dia com sol
mas sua volta à televisão do que nos
estádios e se as pessoas fossem aos
estados
elas iriam ver muitas outras coisas do
pará além daquilo que são as pessoas a
correrem e é nesse sentido
se partirmos sobre esta premissa
entender o futebol como artes que o
estado brasileiro
é guardar a minha reflexão sobre esse
conceito ensino-aprendizagem aplicado à
arte
esta foi a minha primeira tese de
mestrado em que o procura explicar
aquilo que nós pessoas pensarmos que
ensinamos e que o que os alunos
realmente aprendem porque no fundo a lei
um dia aí
muitas vezes temos as coisas na nossa
cabeça mas aquilo que chega outro lado
que o instrumento você tentar passar
pode não ser aquilo que tenho na minha
cabeça de forma clara então fita registo
terá mais um segundo passo e isso basta
que eu resultou neste livro recente em
que o procurei questionar treinadores
que estavam no alto rendimento
quais eram as suas decisões para covatti
de aprendizagem acontecesse
e não falo no momento concreto da
aprendizagem não só no momento concreto
em que nós vamos pôr o treino ou vamos
para o jogo
falo naquilo que está à volta no momento
antes da aprendizagem acontecer a forma
como nós nos prepararmos para quando
vamos dar uma aula a forma como nós nos
preparamos para quando vamos instruir
determinada pessoa porque tudo está aqui
quem dá a pouco em tom de brincadeira
falamos pela anacom sobre ronaldo
isto é tudo verdade nós quando chegamos
o treino quando chegamos a um momento de
ensino-aprendizagem os nossos alunos
os nossos jogadores têm uma vida para
trás daquilo que é o momento e isso é
que é preciso entender eu fui muito na
biologia e fisiologia e sobretudo na
neurociência e neurobiologia como eu
gosto de chamar para entender esse
processo de aprendizagem porém eu acho
que cada vez mais acontece um erro
nós tentamos parar as áreas de estudo
podemos tentar nos sufocar e vivemos a
era dos artigos científicos é preciso
nas universidades publicar artigos
artigos artigos e mais tardios
mas na verdade esquecemos parte das
paredes que vem nos livros sagrados e
agregar os conhecimentos porque na
prática esse então acontecem eu não
consigo chegar ao treino e dizer olha
desculpa mas tu fisiologicamente estação
vo2 máximo
é baixo o teu limite precisamos de fazer
é evoluir para tua capacidade aeróbia
seja melhor não eu não é isso vou falar
da minha linguagem como jogador eu tenho
que ter capacidade de ser mais político
e é nesse sentido que há dois momentos
que marcam o o meu estudo ao longo
desses últimos dez anos
o primeiro foi quando me deparei com
aquilo que foi estudado e vemos aqui
esta imagem que considero bastante
engraçada e trouxe este conceito de
entendermos o homem antes de entendermos
a sua biologia
nós precisamos entender a pessoa antes
de chegarmos ao jogador e surto chegamos
ao artista e quando falamos de artistas
e eu sei que é triste muito especiais
todos os réus são diferentes
e então no futebol eu preciso que
estejam em sintonia para uma ideia para
que as coisas aconteçam
o outro é é um português antónio damásio
na área de neurociência inter mostrou-se
muitos conhecimentos que são
fundamentais para que o que é entender a
aprendizagem e acho que o que marca é
uma das resoluções no processo ensino
aprendizagem com damásio é o erro de
carlos quando eu nos diz que nunca se
deve separar o coração de emoção e por
um simples motivo no processo ensino
aprendizagem
uma das coisas em tomar créditos o
marcador somáticos se neste momento
chegasse que e parte 6ª crê e partir de
agora do sucesso alguma coisa logo à
noite vocês podiam se lembrar de mim
o brasil se lembrar que o partido é
grande alguma coisa aconteceu em frente
nesta sala e isso é que o marcador se
matiko e marcaremos finalmente a pessoa
para que ela aprenda e nós nas escolas
estamos cada vez mais indicados e
assistir o processo de memória e eu
tenho que procurar a matéria eu tenho
que pôr a matéria voltar lá e volta
levou a estudar
nós fomos para a arte isso comprova que
tudo mentira
só quando entra dentro do corpo
só quando chega aquilo em que eu tenho
realmente focado o não consciente é que
as coisas vão acontecer e não conjunto
como eu costumo dizer que está atrás na
parte de trás da nossa cabeça
só quando a ação chega e faz parte do
corpo é que ela realmente vai ser
introduzida e captada o jogador
o pintor o músico muitas vezes não está
a pensar conscientemente como seu córtex
pré frontal na sua ação
vocês acreditam que o jogador quando tem
a bola no pé vai ser capaz de ouvir o
treinador lado banco dizer
direita-esquerda mata chuta passa isso é
tudo mentira
isso é aquilo que nós vemos muitas vezes
na televisão quando o artista tenha a
bola no pé a sua capacidade está
dependente das vivências que até lhe
aconteceram de quantidade de
experiências que eu fui tendo e essa é
quem realmente é grande diferença e nos
preocupamos muito com o consciente
outra das estratégias é descoberta
guiada foi muito célebre por josé
mourinho quando começou a introduzir no
treino e tem a ver com o questionamento
outra das estratégias que nós vemos eo
querido usar e ela também é sugerida por
damásio e descoberta de água em nossa
vantagem nos pistões
a pessoa que está a tentar aprender em
não dar um soluções e muitas das vezes
estamos preocupados em dizer abriu na
esquerda para se ver agora chuta agora
mata não se tivesse aberto na esquerda
acha que é capaz de ser boa
muitas vezes pode ser questão certa ou
errada eu tenha obrigado a pensar sobre
a relação para que no momento de
executar o artista tem a sua liberdade
tem aquilo que ela é capaz de fazer e
não e não esteja constrangido pelo
consciente da informação que está a se
ver pela pessoa que está a tentar
destruir de forma errada porque está
comprovado cientificamente que ninguém
consegue estar a ouvir e captar e
assimilar informação e escutar uma ou
outra mas pensem no pintor pensa no
jogador
e naquilo que vocês quiserem da outra e
mais recente também como livro de
antónio damásio estranha estranho a
ordem das coisas
falamos sobre as imagens
o nosso cérebro não consegue pensar em
imagens em movimento pensarmos em faro
lisboa em todos os países que a gente já
visitou quando vamos pensar nas memórias
que nós temos
elas são imagens são coisas paradas ea
distância que está entre uma imagem e
aquilo que o artista vai executar é o
seu talento e nós muitas vezes tentamos
influenciar esta parte é que o que está
em transformação a imagem que passamos e
aquilo que a sua execução e repito
saldos do futebol mas falta dos alunos
nas escolas falta o pintor saúde e arte
e os links essencialmente é tentar
ajudar a perceber como funciona o
processo ensino aprendizagem da arte
porque eu considero que o futebol é arte
é isto
[Aplausos]
eu não mostrar o estudo pela coxinha que
o messi fez estragos essencialmente pela
ligação que o treinador está na bancada
teve o que importa é valorizamos o
processo
andámos demasiado preocupados em
valorizar os gols desta vida é em
valorizar os resultados finais não as
rodadas finais sem processo
esse processo dá muito trabalho é
preparar e nós cada vez mais estamos
preocupados e influenciar o ato de
decisão do que tentar influenciar o pré
o processo da história preparar o
processo é preciso esperar o treino mais
cedo 30 45 minutos antes é preciso
chegar mais cedo a aula que os meus
alunos como sou professor é preciso uma
série de coisas que andam erradas no
processo ensino aprendizagem porque o
seu treinador mas antes de treinador
eu sou professor e tenho plena
consciência como é que o atual processo
sim se encontra
eu aconselhava a que as pessoas
chegassem minutos mais cedo às aulas e
preparassem sílvio que pensassem no seu
fio de condução das aulas
isso raramente acontece é uma pena
porque nós preocupamo nos muito pouco
com o processo
este senhor é o irã o android foi
jogador treinador do bar fone é holandês
e foi uma das pessoas mais formidáveis
na história do futebol foi um dos
grandes pensadores daquilo que é chamado
ainda hoje jogo posicional
vocês devem se lembrar do tiki taka do
personagem e eu trouxe uma perspectiva
de cultivo para o futebol que eu estava
nos apresentar os nomes que vimos pensar
que o jogador só tem três minutos o jogo
a bola no pé
falamos de médios falamos os jogadores
têm mais tempo a bola no pé porque os
jogadores que em média só tem 1 minuto 2
agora no pé ea diferença está nos outros
87 minutos
os outros 87 minutos é quando o jogador
não tem a bola e quando está a defender
ou e quando o seu colega tenha a bola no
ataque mas nesses 87 minutos e quando
funciona é a parte da frente da nossa
cabeça o nosso coxim e 8 87 minutos é
maior parte do seu tempo acontece
conosco em todas as nossas vidas em
todas as nossas ações é maior parte do
tempo
nós estamos sim é tentar estar
confiantes de que estamos a fazer os
meus caros o problema é ensinar ou
aprender os outros três minutos que
fazem a diferença é o talento é que uns
têm e outros não têm
mas aquelas três minutos é preciso
proporcionar liberdade e conteste porque
todos nós nas nossas vidas seja no
futebol ou seja em qualquer outra área
da sociedade
sejamos capazes de executar e quando
buscava missão de ensinar e sim ainda
complica muito mais porque ensinar a
fazer arte é muito difícil porque todos
nós temos a nossa opinião
agora fazer arte o artista precisa muita
liberdade
e é nesse sentido que neste livro
decidir como um treinador que eu tentei
pensar e procurar seus depoimentos os
treinadores alto nível foi em primeiro
lugar pensar nas pessoas
todos nós temos nossos objetivos na vida
pessoais e profissionais
e não podemos esquecer assim como quais
são as estratégias que nós usamos para
formar um grupo de trabalho para formar
uma equipa
eu valorizo o aniversário do meu colega
valorizo o aniversário dos filhos deu
quando o jogador chega a arranhar a
terminou o treino eu vou cumprimentar o
que eu cheguei antes de eu sei que se
passa com vida a deus está tudo bem
será que às vezes até um familiar está
mais lento e precisa se preocupar com
isso e as estratégias como esta é ainda
um projecto assenta qual se desligará em
braga nem f3m projecto desporto em que
criavam torneios para que as pessoas
pudessem socializar gol é profícuo
nestas situações em que devemos
valorizar o lado humano ea biologia das
coisas
dou um exemplo paulinho do parceiro do
sporting que era um simples evento
quando chegou a ter mil do sporting e
não sabia andar e não sabia falar hoje
em dia é uma pessoa completamente
integrada porque se acreditou na
biologia das coisas mas nunca esqueceu o
lado humano e esse é o meu pensamento
em jeito de sims a cartela prémio nobel
da economia em 2017
apresentamos um conceito para mim e
vereador em súmula
tentei trazer não tenho certezas os
conseguir fazer chegar ao conceito de
média
traduzido para português já pra qualquer
coisa como empurrão para as coisas
porque é que o que eu procuro fazer
todos os dias
é dar um empurrão para que as idéias que
tenho na minha cabeça vão essencialmente
acontecer esta imagem que os represento
aqui é do hospital público de braga e
são umas escadas tem as calorias que
cada pessoa gasta por pela paz que dá ao
lado está um inovador e tenho certeza
que qualquer pessoa que se deparam com
essas casas e com a porta do elevador o
lado vai ter curiosidade subir as
escadas e isto é o que eu tento montar
todos os dias no meu processo de
escolhas que apresento aos meus
jogadores é influenciá-los aqueles pés
em aquilo que devem fazer
e esta é uma das minhas ideias
aí o preocupar me mais como não
consciente e não consciente é que o
vulgarmente o maior parte 12 na pura e
inconsciente
porém é um conceito errado na
aprendizagem porque inconsciente é a
ausência de consciência é quando estamos
desmaiados ou mortos
o que nós temos que trabalhar eu não
conscientes de onde acontece a
espontaneidade a criatividade intuição
tudo aquilo que pertence a arte e para
terminar
gostava de vos deixar pra que eu tenho é
o dilema o dilema que também apresenta
no meu livro que é lembrado na maior
parte do tempo
nós agimos porque pensamos ou seja são
os mais confiantes ou pensarmos porque
agimos e temos mais novos não consente
eu não sei qual é o certo não colou
errado
sei que há momentos na vida em que
vivemos temos mais aplicados do que
outros
enquanto treinador enquanto vergou
instrutor
eu procuro privilegiar os outros
aprendam com textos não confiante
pensando em fugir porque nunca sabe se
vai agir e pensar só isso pensar depois
de agir
obrigado foi um prazer estar aqui
[Música]